[Music]
they're smooth like butter and pull in
las vegas in like no other
good job all right the k-pop group bts
performs the first of four concerts at
the legion stadium tomorrow night now
take a look here this is a live picture
from the stadium where hopefully we can
get the shot right there there you go
all right so there's a couple of folks
that are still making their way over to
that exclusive area for to get all their
gear for the concert and all the craze
began before sunrise
you never really expect what is ever
going to happen especially with like bts
like their music like what they produce
bts fever continues to sweep around the
globe and las vegas is no exception the
k-pop group taking over the town with
four sold-out concerts and their fan
base known as bts army can't get enough
i've been wanting this blanket literally
for like ever so finally got it because
it sells out super quickly
and then i also got this hoodie julie
and her friends are from out of town
they rushed to allegiant stadium for
official merchandise sales at two in the
morning along with thousands more the
fans are collectors we like to collect
various items t-shirts jackets
especially exclusive
items melody lee is a las vegas resident
and part of the local bts army but good
luck finding her this week she's hitting
all the themed pop-up spots on and off
the strip over the course of several
days i went to the photo exhibit already
fantastic they it was basically like a
museum of all of their photos from their
concerts i also went to the pop-up shop
which was
amazing it was very interactive fans
spending hundreds and even thousands of
dollars on merchandise on top of the
concert hotel and travel expenses which
they say is all worth it honestly having
like the time of your life because
that's exactly what they want from you
is to have like the time of your life
and just to go out there and like make
the most of everything that you can do
all right tonight las vegas will be
welcoming bts and their army of fans
with a citywide marquis takeover now for
one night only several marquis along the
strip will shine purple which is the
group's color representation of love oh
even the bellagio getting in on all this
action right with a new fountain show
celebrating the group's hits butter and
dynamite bts members got a sneak peek
earlier this week but it officially
launches tonight at 8 and will run on
rotation this weekend as well as next
whoo-hoo